Let's uh get started good afternoon and
welcome everyone to the Simon's
Institute breakthrough lecture which
today will be on strong bounds for three
progressions by Raghu Mecca so my name
is venkat guruswamy and I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simons Institute
first a brief blurb about the Simon's
Institute because I mean this is a talk
which is streamed and you know those may
not be familiar the Simons Institute is
the leading international venue for
collaborative research in theory of
computing it was established in 2012
with a generous Grant from the Simon's
Foundation who also continued to support
the institute in a very generous in
various ways and The Institute brings
together the world's leading researchers
in theoretical computer science and
related fields as well as the next
generation of outstanding Scholars and
this is the 10th year of actual programs
at the Simon's Institute and we're
really proud of for the achievements of
the programs which have pushed the
frontiers of TCS in so many directions
they have resolved many long standing
open problems and also have opened up
new lines of inquiry and lots of
connections with other fields
so in addition to hosting thematic
semester programs as its principal Focus
the assignments Institute also conceives
and hosts various Outreach activities to
share the exciting developments in the
field with the TCS research community at
large as well as the General Public
and today we have a lecture as part of
the institute's Breakthrough series
which showcases exciting breakthroughs
in the theory of computing or related
fields to the scientific community
today's breakthroughs lecture is about
remarkable progress on a very old
problem in combinatorial mathematics and
number Theory how many numbers can one
pick while avoiding three of them lining
up in a sequence in an arithmetic
progression and it's yet another
compelling illustration of how theory of
computing is intertwined with
mathematics and enables surprising
progress in math as well and this
breakthrough is by Xander Kelly and
Raghu Mecca and our speaker today is
Raghu Meka who I'll briefly introduce
now
so Raghu is a faculty member in computer
science at the University of California
Los Angeles he received his PhD from UT
Austin in 2011 and after that he was a
postdoc at the IIs in Princeton and at
dimax in Rutgers and after that he had a
stint as a researcher at Microsoft
research in Silicon Valley and before
moving to his current position at UCLA
he also spent extended time at MIT
recently on a sabbatical
and he has amazingly broad interests in
the foundations of computer science
particularly algorithm design complexity
Theory pseudorandomness and machine
learning lately and his findings and on
three progressions are only one of his
many notable accomplishments in a
diverse range of topics and uh so before
I hand over the floor to him just a
reminder that this is a hybrid event so
just uh for people in the room to ask
questions just raise your hand we'll try
to pass the mic to you and I will also
be monitoring the Q a on the the zoom
Channel and um so so if there are
questions there I'll pass them on to
Raghu or depending on uh sometimes I
might just decide to batch process them
towards the end so we will uh make that
call so um and and last thing I wanted
to say is that we have the official part
of the talk is a one hour thing and
after that
um what Raghu has kindly agreed to do is
uh a bit of a deep dive into any
technical aspects which people might be
interested in for about half an hour
afterwards and that part um will not be
um will just be for the in-person
audience and would not be uh recorded
okay so with that please join me in
welcoming
thanks
um
so this is based on joint purpose under
family
so the problem that we study is due to
air Edition Quran who asked in 1936 who
asked the following question suppose you
have a subset of integers all we know
about the subset of integers from one
through n is that it has many elements
and throughout the stock I'll use uh
compared to the density of the set as
its size relative to the universe so
what fraction of elements does it
contain and here I'm denoting it by
Delta
so the question they asked is how small
can this density be while always
guaranteeing that you'll find three
numbers
which are equally spaced or three
numbers in an arithmetic progression
and for the rest of the talk I'll just
say 3 AP for short for three term
arithmetic progression
and foreign
Give an example saying that you cannot
get really really good results here in
the sense that
there exists
sets of density roughly 2 to the minus
square root log n which do not contain
any three numbers in a sequence
and this is a beautiful geometry
construction which also has applications
surprisingly to some communication
protocols that I'll talk about in the
very end of the talk
and since then there's also been a lot
of work on the problem particularly with
the seminal worker starting with the
seminal work of Roth from 1953 we showed
that you do indeed find do indeed start
finding arithmetic progressions as soon
as a density is at least one hour log
log n
as long as you have some fraction of
elements you are going to find three
numbers in a sequence and this was
exponentially improved by heat pronouns
I'm already who input the density
so the main question is how small the
density so we're always kind of slowly
improving the density
uh in the sequence of words I'm also
skipping many works here there's a
registry on this problem it's almost 70
years old I'm only kind of covering the
things which are important when showing
up in the rest of the talk
so Bergen in 99 and 08 introduced an
important technique called boar sets
which we also use and also improved the
density bound that you require to find
data mathematic progressions
and Sanders in 2011 kind of got close to
one hour logarithmic density
and this is something that will play a
role later on in our work as well
but for many of these older techniques
it seemed like one hour log was a
barrier that you couldn't overcome but
it was overcome in a very nice work to
the blue men's task we showed that even
if you're set is small enough that its
density is only one over log n to 1.01
so
you're slightly worse off than
logarithmic density by small constant
exponent even then you're going to find
three-time arithmetic progressions and
the OnePlus C might not seem that
significant but was actually very
significant because it gave the first
progress on another Heritage problem in
number Theory which I don't have time to
discuss today
and what we show in this work is the
true answer must actually be closer to
Veterans construction from 1946
that even for quasi-polynally small sets
we are going to start finding our three
term arithmetic progressions and using
the term quasi polynomial in a loose
sense here
don't give me about it but basically
density which is 2 to the minus log n to
the small exponent on top of that okay
so getting closer to Baron's answer than
to the previous constructions
so this is the main result and
before saying a little bit more about it
let me take a detour I should also say
that we don't just say that unlike like
most of these works we don't just say
that there is a single threat of
arithmetic progression once you find one
you also find many many three term
arithmetic progressions
okay
so you get almost a quadratic number of
three thermometer progressions as long
as your density is not too small
so let's take a detour to
finite fields and I'll tell you why in a
little bit so the question that we're
studying can be understood as follows
you have a subset of integers a one
through n of size Delta times n
and what we want are three distinct
numbers a b and c from the same set
which satisfy the equation a plus b is 2
times C
so K plus b is 2 times C then they form
an arithmetic progression and that's
what we're looking for
and we can also ask for a similar
question not just our integers but also
over other groups or in this case even
just finite fields
so now I have some final fill fq to the
n and I have a subset a of integers of
fq to the N the density is still Delta
and we're looking for the same thing as
before we want three unequal elements
ABC from your set a we satisfy the
equation a plus b is 2C
and usually integers are harder than
finite Fields finite fields are an
easier space to work with and yeah here
also something similar happens
and in fact something drastic happens
what do I mean Baron's lower bound
construction no longer works
what Baron showed was that there was an
AP free set of density roughly 2 to the
minus square root log n that
construction does not work for finite
fields
and it doesn't work very good reason
in 2017 a couple of papers in a
breakthrough showed that
even exponentially small sets must have
three term arithmetic progressions over
finite Fields so even if your density is
exponentially small compared to the size
of the inverse you must find three-time
arithmetic progressions
and the case where the field Q is uh F3
it's called the capset problem
and that's what I'm going to focus on
for the rest of the talk too just for
clarity it doesn't change any of the
math or any of the conceptual
difficulties and techniques that we are
going to see
okay so you know just think of
e to the n you have a subset I want to
find three elements from this set which
have satisfied the equation a plus b
equals to C
and we are good
so this work which shows that
exponentially small sets must also
satisfy must can must also have three
automatically progressions to use a
beautiful algebraic technique where the
proof was by the polynomial method and
it doesn't quite carry the integers and
it shouldn't right because we we know
that we cannot get such exponentially
good paths over integers
from the other hand the previous methods
of Roth heat burn and Seminary you know
brucane Sanders Bloom into Sask and so
on they all use analytic techniques to
prove the statements of the issue
analytic meaning they use for your
analysis and all of those things
and these methods can be pushed to
integers in fact and often a commonly
seen theme across this myth this works
is the first work or finite Fields maybe
for exposition or for clarity and then
kind of translate the arguments to
integers
okay
and that's actually what we also do so
we give an analytic proof that subsets
of density
polynomially small density must also
have three term arithmetic progressions
and this is our finite Fields as stated
this result is much weaker than what we
know our finite Fields but the point is
that we are going to use analytic
methods which we can then push it push
to integers right and translating with
integers actually is a lot of work but
it involves
many other techniques which have been
developed but today I'm only going to
focus on
the finite field case and subsequent to
our work a Blue Man's task in Apollo get
a much cleaner way to translate our
arguments and finite fields to integers
and along the way also got some new
improvements from any other questions
right
okay so rest of the talk the setup is as
follows we just have a subset a of fq to
the N think again Q equals 3 F3 to the N
density is Delta and we want three
unequal elements ABC we satisfy the
equation a plus b is 2C
the proof has three ingredients the
first ingredient is really the bread and
butter in this in the area in this area
in additive combinator it's in general
which is structure versus Randomness all
right
and in fact I would say one of the most
important
reasons for studying the VIP problem is
that it's being kind of uh
the origin nature of many techniques
which have had many other applications
not just in United combinatorics but
also within TCS extractor versus
Randomness this dichotomy and so on have
many other applications
okay so that's the first step the second
part is kind of new to our work which
I'll call Spectral positivity and I'll
tell you what that means and how we use
it later on the final ingredient is a
Technique we call sifting for finding
area2 substructures by using some kind
of algorithmic tool
let me start by describing the standard
approach that
um
standard Paradigm of structure versus
Randomness but finding thetomagnetic
progressions okay
okay
so what is the structure versus manual
it's really just a win-win Wishful
argument
so what's a Wishful argument so let's
suppose the thought experiment that you
pick your set a completely at random
all we know I'll be new to begin with
was the set had something sex that was
the only constraint but let's say you
know you were just picking the set to
have density Delta and at random how
many three term arithmetic progressions
would you expect in such a side how many
solutions to the equation a plus b
equals to C would you expect if the set
a was random
well there n Square such triples once I
know A and B this third choice is fixed
so there are capital N squared many such
triples and each triple is
Delta Q has Delta Cube chance to be in
your set a
right each of them is being chosen
independently we're just doing a thought
experiment we feel very lucky the number
of solutions to your equation in a
should be Delta Cube times N squared
that is if you said a is completely at
random
and this is much more than the number of
trivial Solutions then you must have
many good arithmetic progressions
so the wish one the win case one the
structure versus Randomness is maybe
this heuristic argument can be made to
work even if my set is close to uniform
in some sense
okay so you want some notion of
closeness to uniform which will tell us
that okay if you're close to uniform in
some sense then you get many three APS
okay so that's even one product
well what not all sets must be close to
uniform what do you do if you're not
close to uniform
that's the second thing that we need
we're not close to uniform but you said
it looks something like this you would
like to say that you can identify some
structure in this set I don't know if
anyone can see the structure here yet
but
if your distribution a the uniform
distribution is far from uniform then
you want to say that some structure
arises within it and we make some
progress whatever that progress is
in particular in the picture that I
showed if you look at it at a certain
angle all the points lie in the small
affine space okay you do a plane all the
points were in that plane
that's the ideal scenario for us either
you're close to uniform in which case
we're already done otherwise
there is some Subspace V on which you
have more elements than you should have
to begin with on average okay
so there's some successfully where the
size of a restricted to V is more than
Delta times the size of the overall
ambient space so you have a density
increment
if this is the case then we made some
progress in the sense that I can focus
on just the space V
and this is the beauty of finite Fields
why everything is kind of nicer or
finite Fields once I move to the
Subspace V it's as if I'm starting with
the same question again
so everything is isomorphic so you can
just do it's as if I'm just working with
F3 again whatever smaller dimensional
space but I'm starting with a higher
density
okay
but of course as stated you know I can
then do induction on V or just recurse
on V and keep doing this but as stated
this would be a silly thing to hope for
because events and I can just say okay
here's my single point in a is a
Subspace of Dimension B and I have
density incremental one
that's a meaningful
we also need to look for a Subspace V
which is big
okay you can't just say there's some
small Subspace on which you have many
elements you want to say that there is a
large space where you have more elements
that you should have started to begin
with
so the largest of the Subspace for us
will be measured in terms of the core
Dimension core Dimension is just saying
how many extra constraints are you
placing on your Subspace so it's n minus
the overall dimension
of the substance
okay
so that's the template
let's go back to Ross original argument
let's just do a quick walkthrough of
what of what Roth did and then we'll try
and modify it to see uh to get the new
box and this is based on the it's called
The Rock micheliner argument and it goes
as follows
so what is the notion of closeness that
they studied
so again as I said you have a which is
F3 to the n
and they said if the set a is
almost random in the sense that it is
small biased it's something that we all
said in theoretical computer science
then it has many three APS
small bias just means that the uniform
Distribution on the set a
looks random to simple linear tests
so in particular if I pick X uniform let
random from a and add up the the
elements or they add the coordinates of
X it takes the value 0 with probability
roughly one third it takes a value of
one with probability roughly one third
two with probability one third there's
some error Delta but as long as this
error is like a constant Factor worse
than Delta you do get many treatments
yeah that's which one closeness is
defined by whether you're not your full
linear test and if you're full linear
test you do get many three ethics
the part two is if you're not small bias
then almost by definition
there is a linear test which is telling
your set apart from a uniformly random
distribution and that gives you a
density increment
so you can find an affine space in fact
core Dimension One onto which you
increase the density but the density
increment is somewhat small you started
out with density Delta you started out
with something which has Delta fraction
of elements now you have Delta plus
Delta squared
slight Improvement but not you know it's
just something
and so the template then is you know you
started out with the original set a and
your whole Space F3 to the N you have
Delta fraction of elements if you have a
piece then you're good if you don't have
any APS then you must have density
increment onto a Subspace of
co-dimension one
she went from Delta to Delta plus Delta
squared reduced the dimension by 1. if
you have a piece you're done otherwise
you do the same thing again it becomes 2
Delta Square keep repeating
if I do this one over Delta iterations
then it's your density increases by some
constant Factor
and you can now do some other stuff to
get a contradiction because density
cannot ever be more than one
okay and the limit to this argument is
that each time you do it
you are adding one extra constraint your
core Dimension is one you can you cannot
ever add more than n constraints so this
argument works as long as the density is
one over n
so as a sketch we just saw the proof of
this theorem
this finite field version of Roth's
argument if I have a subset of F3 to the
n and it has one over n fraction of
elements then it has many three APS
within it
so this is a template that we're going
to start with this is structure versus
randomness 101.
where do we go from here how can we go
beyond
so the two ingredients here one was
defining this notion of closeness to
uniform which allowed us to immediately
say you have many three APS and then the
second part in the Roth micheliner
argument
was how small a Subspace do you find can
you find how large a Subspace can you
find
before your density becomes larger by
constant Factor
[Music]
in the old argument you had to do with
many steps you had to go to code I
mentioned one over Delta to increase the
density by constant Factor can we
improve this
in particular we will be looking for
poly log one on Delta but you don't have
to pay too much attention to the actual
parameters they'll come out more
naturally but just keep this template in
mind
all right
okay let's focus on the first step
what notion of closeness would be enough
so they use closeness as measured by
fooling linear tests but let's take a
minimal approach minimalist approach
let's start working backwards from what
would actually be enough to guarantee us
that you have many three APS
stand that let's look at our equation
again
we have some set a and we want distinct
elements ABC such that a plus b equals
to C
a convenient shorthand that people use
in this literature is summing sets okay
so meaning a plus a is instead of you
take all pairs all distinct pairs and
just add them up to get a new set
2 times a is just you take all elements
in the set a and multiply them by two
with this new notation what we want
becomes
this equation we want to say that a plus
a intersect to a is not empty in fact we
want something more quantitative we want
to say that this intersection is big in
some sense
and what says should we just count the
number of elements in this intersection
not quite that does not the right thing
to do because when you look at the sums
at a plus a some elements might be
representable in many different ways as
some of two things or something might I
have a unique representation and if I
throw two dice there's only one way to
get two whereas there are many ways to
get the number seven
take discounts also into account right
would be nicer to take that into account
and the right way to quantify it turns
out to be the following
suppose I pick a uniformly random
element X from a and then Y is also a
uniformly random name but it's
independent
what is the chance that there's some
ends up in this set two times a
if the chance that the sum is ends up in
two times is Big then we must have many
many three elements
okay because it's giving you many pairs
a plus b which are lying in two times a
so you're good
that's the way we are going to quantify
what we want and here I'm putting Omega
Delta because this is what you would get
per random set
it is a random set then the only thing
we know about two times density is Delta
so maybe X Plus y should land within it
with probability Delta
seems too Wishful but let's see what we
get if this is what we focus on
but before that
what is the distribution of h plus one
I know the distribution of x and they
take an independent copy Y and add them
up what distribution do I get
well this is probability 101. here I
actually do random numbers from one
through ten thousand you get some dense
with density I think 0.01 or something
the PDF f x is shown in blue
and the density function the
distribution of X Plus Y is shown in
magenta it's much nicer smoother kind of
flatter and everything is nicer about
the density of X Plus 5.
and we actually have a closed form
expression for what the distribution of
X Plus Y is
is the convolution of the distributions
that you started out with
in fact two random variables then the
distribution of the sum of them is given
by the convolution of the original
distributions we started out with
okay so if I denote mu a as the density
of x
then the density of two add some of two
independent copies is Mu a convolved
with new a
and here just to be clear I'm using the
density notion the normalization is not
very important but that's one that is
easiest to carry around
so we're thinking of the Distribution on
a it's being normalized so that instead
of adding up to one that's expectation
is one
and the convolution operation is what
you see in probability Theory and
everywhere else so F star G is
expectation over some random element Z
of uh f and g evaluated at points where
they add up to X
and we also look at something called
difference convolution where instead of
looking at the sum you look at the
difference of the two things okay so
what's the expectation of f evaluated at
a point and G evaluate to point where
the difference of the two is conditioned
to be X
in the usual convolution you take the
sum here you're taking the difference
all right
okay so let's keep that in mind that the
distribution of the sum of two
independent copies is given by the
convolution and let's look back at the
note the condition that we want we want
X Plus y the distribution of X Plus y to
kind of be uniform in the sense that it
hits the small set a with some
noticeable probability
the word is special about this set to a
is there something important that
uh the set a is also used in the
definition of X and Y or maybe all they
care about it at this point is that it
has some number of elements
so you're going to take a leap of faith
and just ask for something much stronger
so I'm going to ask that
you have X and Y drawn independently at
random then the sum X Plus Y is almost
uniform for the entire space in the
sense that
any not too small set gets hit the right
fraction
If X Plus y was indeed uniformly
distributed then the probability that it
lacks in the set T is exactly Delta and
we're saying okay I want such a strong
condition not just that it's true for 2A
but for every set T the chance that you
land within it is maybe Delta over 10
Delta over 2 something some constant
Factor
so what does this mean so let's look at
a picture very character caricaturous
picture so the x-axis is all possible
elements in the financial let's see to
the n and the y-axis I'm just writing
down the chance that X Plus y actually
takes that value so it's the density of
X plus one
for reference the truly uniform
distribution would always be the
constant value which is the yellow line
here
and if this is a heating property that I
want and I show you the density what
would be the worst fee to pick
the worst tea to pick would be all those
things which are where the value is very
small
so I look at all possible points where
the chance of taking them is small 0.1
and let me focus on those elements in
the universe
if this region has higher Mass there are
many many points like this then I'm in
trouble
then I am not satisfying the heating
property
so so far it's just almost by definition
and here I'm going to actually make that
a formal definition and call a density
anti-concentrated
we're calling it Delta anticoncentrated
here but forget as I said you know I'll
be loose with the parameters Delta
because we're just going to keep one
parameter throughout
if
the probability that the density takes a
value less than 0.1 is not large
in fact if it's a uniform distribution
it's always one so this probability
should be zero enable angle you have
some error so I'm saying you can take
the value less than 0.1 but it should
not take it more often than Delta
okay so it's anti-concentrated meaning
you're not going to take a small value
with the non-negligible probabilities
all right and the notion of closeness to
uniform is going to be very different
from Roth's argument so they studied
just linear tests and now we are going
to say a is close to uniform
if the density of a convolved with
itself is anti-concentrative
meaning once a convolve a with itself
you have the heating property any big
set will be hit any not too small set
will be hit the right amount of time
and the first Lemma structure versus
Randomness Lemma would be that if the
density of a will convolved with a is
anti-concentrated then we have many
three acres
any proof of this again as I said is
almost by definition you say okay if
it's anti-concentrated what's the chance
that X Plus y lands within 2A the Delta
fraction of elements and at most Delta
over to where you are point one just do
some arithmetic you get that there are
at least the right almost what you get a
uniform the random set
so to summarize the structure versus not
in this part you have this dichotomy
that you're shooting for win-win
analysis either you're close to uniform
or you get density increment and the
notion of closeness is zeroed in on was
that
the density the of the distribution
convolved with itself is
anti-concentrated
okay so a convolved with itself must be
anti-constant
then you have many APS that's kind of
which one
what we have to do is to do the second
part which is where we kind of push all
of the difficulty down to the second
part to say if you're not
anti-concentrated then you need to
identify some structure then you need to
find some increment onto a Subspace
okay so let me try and talk about that
so any questions about the overall
paradigm
okay
if not let me go on to the second part
which we call Spectral positivity which
allows me sure so was this kind of uh
pseudor Randomness part of any previous
workout
I think who said you would say you know
something like this is into a certain
various work maybe when you go to
spectral policy with that partnership
okay so I mean in some sense so far we
just restated the definition right it's
anti-concentrated then you're good
because you're good for any small set so
in particular for a few times
but the second part spectral positivity
will allow us to get a drastically
different formulation of this at the
Constitution
so again go back to our picture
what do you want now so you have
something so that the distribution
convolved with itself is not
anti-concentrated meaning it's taking
small values more often than it should
yeah so you kind of have this scenario
well this seems like a strange thing to
study but what we have studied in across
many different fields is okay I want to
say you're close to uniform in absolute
sense maybe I have the uniform uh like
the constant one function I could say
you're actually close to the constant
one most of the time that's a better
thing for
to study using various analytic tools
okay
if I want to do something like this
there are two kinds of Errors you see
here
upward errors meaning values where my
this my function my density is taking
values which are much more than one
and there are downward errors which is
what we actually have
where
it's taking two small values too often
okay there are two kinds of Errors you
can have upward errors you can have
downward errors and our assumption is
that you don't have downward errors
and from that we want to get to a
structure statement
unfortunately if you have General
densities
you can actually have distributions
which only have downward errors with no
upward errors I can have a distribution
which looks exactly like this it never
goes too high above one but it goes low
often
but this is the assumption that we
started out with
and for reasons that will become clearer
later so
we argue that such a thing cannot happen
for the specific distributions we study
more generally we show that for a large
class of uh distributions you cannot
have only downward errors as long as
they have this property that we call
Spectral positivity
what is spectral positivity
it's just the condition that any
distribution or any function has Fourier
coefficients
even if your function is not negative
it's Fourier coefficients need not be
non-negative they can be complex numbers
they can be all or negative numbers
whatever
if you say the function is spectrally
positive
if all of its Fourier coefficients are
non-negative
they can be zero but they cannot be
negative or complex
and the condition that we have we show
is that if your distribution is uh
spectrally positive then you cannot have
only downward errors meaning if you're
going low you should also actually come
up often enough
and in particular
if you are spectrally positive and not
anti-concentrated
then some K Norm of your function must
be 1.01
the normalization here is that I mean
the definition of k Norm is just the
expected value of the kth power of the
function
but just think of it as saying that you
are taking the value 1.001 reasonably
often if you are taking the value less
than 0.1 often then you are taking the
value 1.001 also often okay you can't
just be lower you should also go higher
all right
okay that sounds good nice if you have
spectral positivity you have this but
why is that relevant for the problem
that we started out with
well we kind of get lucky because well
because the product of convolutions
right so we are interested in the
distribution a convolves with itself in
fact eight difference convolution with
itself
and whenever you take a convolution of
two distributions in the Fourier domain
the convolution operation is much nicer
in fact the Fourier coefficients of
conversion of two distributions is just
a product ntos for products of the
Fourier coefficients
in particular when you take difference
convolution the new Fourier coefficients
are exactly squares of the absolute
values of the old coefficients so
they're all by definition non-meter
so in particular a convolved with a
defense calculation itself is not
anti-concentrated then it is actually
taking High values some of the time at
least
okay it's not under concentrated then
you should also be deviating upwards not
just downward errors
you might wonder why this switch from
downward errors to Upward errors is
useful intuitively it's because we are
really looking for kind of a lower Bond
we want to say that there is some
Subspace V on which you have density
increment
increment a lower bound on the value
kind of makes sense and quantitatively
everything ends up
so to summarize
spectral positivity says that if you are
not anti-concentrated then I have a
lower bound on a k naught for some
suitable k
we have to now go from here to actually
finding density
so that's the third part so let's start
with the Assumption from now on that a
convolved with a is taking High values
some fraction of the time it's K Norm is
one plus Epsilon Epsilon is some
constant point zero one
and from here we want to get density
so that's the spectral positivity part
which goes allows us to go from kind of
you know not anti-concentrated to taking
large values some fraction of the time
and now we have to find this addictive
substructure from this assumption
so we call our goal the Assumption means
that a convolved with itself has high K
naught it is taking High values some
noticeable fraction of the time and you
want density increment meaning I want a
large affine space where a restricted to
it has a constant Factor more elements
than it started out with
finding an alpha in space is a big ask I
find Space has a lot of structure within
it if you think of an affine space it
has like if you add V to itself you know
think of Subspace given you know forget
I find nature
just think of subspaces
so if I add V to itself I get V back
yeah 10 copies of v i get V back right
so subspaces have a lot more structure
in them and in the overall question here
we're just asking okay find me the
Subspace directly in one go
but instead of that we're going to look
for something weaker which has some
additive structure something like a
Subspace but something in between
and we're going to find increment not
onto a Subspace fully but on to
something in between a Subspace and a
general set called a subset
Sunset is just any set of the form that
any set that can be obtained by adding
two other sets so if I want a large B
where a restricted to the sum of B plus
B has density increment
okay so if you can find a Subspace
obviously finding a subset is easy
because I can take you know V itself B
plus v is V so everything is fine
okay so finding this structure is easier
than finding a Subspace instead of
finding the Subspace directly find me
something where
have density increment with this weaker
constraint maybe I can try and do this
and here let me draw a uh caricature of
the actual argument
I want to describe it abstractly and
then I'll say a few words about what
actually happens uh mathematically
suppose I have some large set s you know
it's some subset of F3 to the n and
there's something hidden in there which
has nice additive structure like a
Subspace or you know when you add it to
itself it's not growing too much and
things like that
is there some operation that I can do to
sift out or identify this portion which
has this nice adjective structure
in this picture I'm going to cheat and
say the structure that I'm trying to
identify is this nice Square grid here
is there some operation that I can do
which can pick out only the square
portion and throughout this other
isolated points
and you know you're trying to sift out
so we actually shift
so you shift your original set
and look what kind of overlaps with
yourself
now imagine
I'm trying to find this square right I
take a shift
along some direction S1
the points in the Square are more likely
to overlap with themselves
you're isolated when you shift you're
just going to random Place nothing
happens but if you have a square I shift
it it overlaps in a significant time
significant fraction with the whole
Square
right do another shift something similar
happens
the points in the Square each time are
more likely to survive than those
outside
a bigger fraction of the additive
substructure would survive than isolated
points if you have a Subspace hidden
inside when you take shifts and
intersect with themselves you would
expect
that portion to survive more often than
not
so that's the main idea behind sifting
you are looking for identifying some
additive substructure especially in this
form of sunset so the way we do it is to
look at this shifting multiple shifts
and intersecting with itself
a lot of math that I mean written up
here
but the end of the day what this is
saying is
a look at the set shifted multiple times
intersected with all of the shifts then
I get a set which is almost closed under
addition with this stuff
if I take a uniformly random X from a
set b a uniformly random y from a set B
then the probability that I end up in my
original set is very high yeah
get a larger substructure if you were to
take a majority
uh instead of intersection I think it's
very brittle like you were finite seals
um
we don't lose that much here we might
get some quantitative Improvement but
there's something that we haven't
considered
so you get some uh set on which
which is close almost close under
addition with itself so it is like a
Subspace property that you are shooting
for
right so this is the main sifting Lemma
which says that look at all points where
my density was giving to higher value
there should be many of them because my
K Norm is Big that's the assumption that
we started out with
then if I apply the shifting operation
on it you get a set B which is not too
small
and B added with itself is almost
entirely contained within my settings
I need when I look at s plus 60 to B
plus b you get density
this is s contained in a
right so basically you have to do
another averaging argument where since
it's only convolution of a with itself
you can transition one of these
convolutions and that gives an affine
shift instead of an actual Subspace
respect to your right you know I'm
hiding something there you're actually
only finding density increment of s onto
a sum set so that implies density
okay so we found a correlated subset
meaning you found some density increment
but what do we do with it we wanted a
Subspace right Subspace is a much more
complicated thing
uh I mean let me skip this there's an
identity behind why
uh the sifting operation works I can
tell you more about it it's a little bit
like a probabilistic method or cross
moment method analysis
presentation is that when you shift and
intersect with itself a Subspace is more
likely to survive these trials than
random points
so how do you go from subsets to
subspaces fortunately for us this has
already been done in many other works
it's also called Almost periodicity and
other works uh Sanders well we use a
specific Lemma called Sandra's invarian
Slimmer from one office one of the
earlier papers
it says that if you get density
increment onto a subset then in fact you
should get density increment also onto a
Subspace no questions asked this is a
generic statement which says that as
long as
any for any function any set s
if B plus b is close to the set s then
is there's also a Subspace onto which
you have density increment the code
Dimension loses a little bit but again
as I said I'm not stressing the
parameters everything works out as it
should
we put the two together our sifting
operation and the known almost
periodicity periodicity or invariance
lemmas
you get the following result that we
were shooting for
if a convolved with itself has K Norm
high it's taking two high values some
fraction of the time its value is 1.01
some fraction of the time then
there is an alpha in space
onto which we get a constant Factor
density increment
and the core Dimension is only poly
logarithmic which is what we want here
so the big Improvement is that in Roth's
original argument you had to go to co
Dimension one over the density to get a
constant Factor increment but now you're
getting only with poly log
okay so there's a k there's a log you
put everything together you get some
bumps
to summarize the proof
in reverse order you have the sifting
operation which tells you that if a
convolved with it with itself is taking
High values some fraction of the time
then you immediately get the other side
of the event situation which is
increment
sorry density increment onto a Subspace
it's small core dimension the spectral
positive dilemma connects this notion
the assumption that you're using here to
not being anti-concentrated
which was just saying that you're not
taking two small values too often
and finally the third piece is just that
if you're not anti-concept if you are
anti-concentrated then you must have
many three
so you put all of these three together
you get uh the result for finite fields
with the right parameters that are
stated at the beginning
going from finite fields to integers is
not something that I'm going to even
touch upon today but it involves many
key technical issues that show up but
use a similar ideas you have to use
spectral positivity again you have to
use sifting but you have to work with
more General distributions you have to
work with something called bore sets at
least let me just say what the
fundamental challenges the fundamental
challenge is you cannot do induction so
nicely over integers
or finite fields we say we found density
agreement on the Subspace and Subspace
are all the same
it's as if you're starting with the same
problem again
whereas in our integers you know you
find something you know maybe even if
you found unless you find an actual
progression onto which you have a
density increment you're not with the
same problem
so you have to keep track of everything
from the beginning but fortunately there
are some standard techniques uh to do
that and we had trouble but I blumens
ask have since like found a more cleaner
argument to do that
which leads us to the main theorem over
integers that any set of integers which
are at least Delta times any
Delta times uh n many elements must have
three term mathematic progressions
so that's all I want to say about the
proof and our result let me finish by
stating new techniques getting any
improvements for the existing bounds on
for automatic progressions would be very
interesting
and finally let me State a question
which is related to three thermodynamic
progressions but actually also has
applications to communication complexity
and it asks for a question like what we
started out with but now we're looking
at subsets of pairs of numbers
the earlier we just had a subset of
integers now I have a subset of pairs of
integers from 1 through M and the
density is still Delta the question is
how small can this density be
while guaranteeing that your set has a
corner inside it corner just means that
I have three points where
three points a c and b where a minus C
the length of it along the x axis is
exactly the length of B minus C along
the y axis
so you need to find three points of the
form X comma y some shift along the X
gives you another point the same shift
along the y coordinate gives you another
point
okay
and parents example also shows that
there exists corner-free sets whose
density is 2 to the minus square root
log n and getting such you know the
results like what we have for Corners
would be very very interesting even our
finite Fields that's not something that
we have
okay so with that let me end
hey thanks Raghu for a great talk we
certainly have time for questions
um let me urge anybody
[Music]
um online there were about 40 of you if
you have any questions please type it up
and they can answer it
not people here well anyone types
questions yeah go ahead I'm just a very
basic question about your uh one of the
the slides about the graph with the
graph which show the density function
right so if if this field is small
enough shouldn't it be for you
choose randomly Point shouldn't it be
very symmetric so there's not going to
be any change if it's integer I
understand
uh it's so let me see
yeah the question was should this plot
be symmetric sometimes yes well I'm just
drawing the uh I don't know
so let me just say that here the x-axis
meant to be the multi-dimensional space
of you know the entire finite field and
the y-axis is just the probability that
particular element
appears scaled by uh scale so that the
normalization should be one
so if you're uniform you're always one
whereas you know if you don't put any
other constraint your density can take
any values as long as this expectation
is one
okay right and Specter positively put
some constraints on what you can get but
without that your density could be any
function here
the only condition would be that its
integral should be one or its
expectation under the informed
distribution here should be one
okay there's one question online which
is what do you think is the tight answer
that is how close to bear and spawn do
you think you can get which is also
related to question I had which is that
if you had this optimal Sanders landmark
and you push it close to half
uh close to half would be difficult I
think so the two places where we lose
one is even our finite fields we only
get log n to the nine
so you lose something in sand or Slimmer
and also you lose something because
[Music]
um
let me show you one place where that
actually shows up
yeah
so
you could think of improving this power
for but even if you improve that I think
you'd get something like uh like you
have a case again bound to be long
so you get log squared but then right
now we're all setting one more log
because this is only constant Factor
increment
so to get a contradiction you have to
repeat it multiple times or find some
way to not do it multiple times you
could do it with for roths argument
but presumably if you do at least the
right standards bound you might get like
log into the one third
maybe from there going to square root
login would not be as not
I guess it's still the first part what
do you think is the tight answer I think
square root locket should be the right
answer is this Justice
I just want to know if this uh this
technique has some implication on
algorithms for funding uh certain
mathematic progressions like you and
integers can you find find some uh AP in
N Square over two to log into Epsilon
time
just speculating
[Music]
sure actually I mean
for the most part like there's one
critical ingredient where we use uh this
is a probabilistic method kind of
argument which you just get existence
foreign
so
we can say okay you pick a random
element then you find an arithmetic
progression that's the easy case
otherwise you have to go through the
sifting operation
and there is a little bit existential in
our current argument we just said there
is some shift which finds you the set
that you're looking for okay you'll find
it with good probability
I mean
maybe not 100 sure because it's like a
past moment method arguments it just
tells you that there should be one sum s
but good will not still be very good I
think
it could still be
positive polynomial these small so maybe
that's okay I don't know
thanks I think it's worth thinking about
another question will take the online
one if it's okay but you
um the two online ones okay so parikshit
asks what do we know about distributions
with all positive Fourier Spectrum are
they all convolutions
that's a good question
I doubt it
I would suspect not
you can cook up strange distributions uh
by rescaling things I think
oh
it's not clear
so that's maybe one more online yeah is
there a simple kuna last is there a
simple intuition for why spectral
positivity lets you translate for
anti-concentration high disk uh actually
I mean I I stated it in a
more General way I mean in a less
General way than it is true to demystify
it
for any random variable what we actually
use is a following we have any random
variable
all of those are Central moments
are non-negative
so all of its odd Central moments are
non-negative then you have this property
X is such that you know all of its odd
moments you know once you take out the
mean or non-negative it is not doesn't
have to be true for
you know most random variables but if
this is true then if you have lower
deviations you also get upward
deviations
and spectral positivity is one immediate
way to directly this because when you
take our Central moments the constant
goes away in the center and then
everything else is non-negative you do
some arithmetic and everything works out
very well
sorry thank you
um earlier in the talk you briefly
mentioned that uh sharpening the density
bounds for the existence of three
progressions had motivations in
communication complexity and I was just
wondering if you could talk a bit more
about that sure so it relates to this
Corner's problem
and
let me okay so the connection is from an
upper bound if you have a three AP free
set then you can use it to solve the
following communication problem in some
non-trivial way so what's the
communication problem there are three
players
who each get a number from 1 through n
written on their forehead
so this Alice Bob and Charlie Alice can
see the two numbers written on top of
Bob and Charlie and by and then the same
thing for the other people
and they're just checking they're done
they want to do a sump check which is
okay is the sum of the three numbers n
over two
everyone is getting number from one
through capital N an integer and they
want to know if they add up to something
which is exactly Capital node
so that's the communication problem
nothing to do with IPS
right the trivial protocol is of course
for Alice to shout out let's say Bob's
number and then Charlie knows and then
Bob knows everything and they can just
finish the computation
this takes log of capital N many bits
because you have to write an entire
number Baron's example gives you a
protocol a square root login
communication
and that's the best protocol we know
and lower bounds wise we know that any
protocol must take like log log capital
and benefits so this is Cap log log n
versus greater log n
and if you had better
bet then you could get better protocols
so at least this works is that you
cannot get substantially better
protocols using this approach
the general question of lower bonding
protocols
okay I don't see any other questions
online and since anyway we planted oh
okay
yeah I sort of had two bigger picture
questions one is um so you mentioned the
fourth term case
I mean can you say anything about
you know the K term cases K goes to the
infinity
is the answer to that known and also
I'm not know a bit about van der verden
numbers and you know Green has this
result about how long a three
progression
can go without how do you how do you
relate what you're doing to Van Der
verden numbers and is there any cross
uh you mean like Vanderburgh and Theorem
or yeah yeah and you know so Vander I
mean Vander verden's theorem is
two-sided you know either the the
integers that are included have a
three-term or the complement as a three
term but you're looking at only one side
so I'm just wondering if is there any
crossover
um
I'm not entirely sure exactly the thing
that you're talking about but there's a
coloring version of the same thing where
you don't just ask for
uh like
um
three APS when you have a small when you
have a large set but let's say I ask you
know can you color the numbers from one
to n with few colors
so that at least one of the colors has a
created so there are three numbers which
are the same color and are in sequence
so typically going from density to
coloring version is almost the same
there's some loss you lose the
logarithmic bound
yeah
which would have been bad for the
earlier bounce but like you know with at
least with this 2 to the minus log n to
the point zero nine it doesn't affect
the bio
at least in that context it's the same
but uh I'm not sure the exact thing that
you maybe chat out
whatever
okay um let's maybe take uh further
questions offline and as I said Raghu
will stick around for sort of a deep
dive into any technical questions you
might have
um so
um so thanks again Raghu for an awesome
talk
foreign